my name is Tycho ytt I am the director
of Thor Ragnarok ultimately this film is
about Thor Ragnarok and his journey to
some outer space places people often
asked me why did you become a filmmaker
well the main reason just wanted impress
my mum and dad and to show them I'm not
a loser
I get what you stay I can achieve some
dreams not my own dreams but other
people's dreams I can get close to being
JJ Abrams I know you wanted him as a son
well you got me I'm sorry I'm not JJ
Abrams they say I don't wish we pulled
you JJ Abrams would have been so much
cooler you died on Star Wars
well it didn't all right mum and dad I
didn't you stuck with me okay now down
to the nitty-gritty why did I make this
film for a kudos and followers on
Twitter what I really wanted to do with
Thor was capture the essence of Peter
Pan but a little bit of Terminator 2
a dash of independence day a smidgen of
on Golden Pond with a kind of tone of
beaches mixed in with my fair lady so
Arthur we've achieved that at the end of
the day we're all said and done the
films about two monsters some explosions
pretty ladies handsome men there's a
Hulk then it's the credits are dead all
the names of the people who made it
that's what we tried to do and I think
we did it that's what I wanted to
achieve with this film or respect from
Taika Waititi from New Zealand